mubarak was flown off the prison grounds
to a military hospital in cairo
the helicopter flight lasted only a few
minutes
the news dismayed many egyptians hosni
mubarak was allowed to leave jail and
enter house arrest
while the country's democratically
elected president mohammed mursi
remains in custody after a military coup
it's a blow to mursi's islamist
supporters but also to the activists of
the 2011
arab spring it was their protests on
cairo's tarya square
that forced mubarak to step down
hundreds were killed in clashes with
regime forces
mubarak is being tried for complicity in
their deaths
now the police state will return
injustice will return
and every other negative thing that we
hoped was gone is back
they've released mubarak and everyone
else in the former regime
what's left is for him to rule us again
but the 85 year old mubarak still has
many supporters
this man served egypt for many years but
in his last 10 years he was attacked
i believe that he was a victim of the
actions of the people he was surrounded
is now up to the courts his trial
continues
even though he'll no longer have to
await its outcome in custody